merveilleuse
abnégation pour les enfants
de grande communication
je m'appelle Claude Benard pillier et je
suis bénévole à l'atelier du Petit
Prince qui fait partie de la Ligue
contre le cancer
je ferai quelque chose pour les pour les
gens avec une autre collègue ils ont
décidé de fonder
l'association du Petit Prince je sais
qu'on peut dans le milieu associatif on
peut on peut donner de l'argent on peut
envoyer des cadeaux mais je voulais
vraiment agir
bonjour
on fait partie de l'équipe je peux le
dire de l'équipe médicale qui nous
soutient de façon extraordinaire donc
quand on arrive on arrive un peu chez
nous bonjour
moi je m'appelle Claude laissez-moi je
fais partie du Petit Prince trouver
de donner une partie de soi-même et quoi
son temps déjà
bon quand un enfant vient il vient pour
plusieurs mois plusieurs années de
traitement un quart à peu près des
enfants de notre service qui sont
malheureusement originaires de la zone
Océan Indien et donc non accompagné de
leurs parents ça permet aux enfants du
service de s'évader de penser à autre
chose pendant le temps de la présence
des bénévoles
moi sincèrement c'est ma thérapie c'est
je me suis engagée là dedans suite à la
maladie que j'ai rencontrée de près dans
ma famille c'est une façon pour moi de
relever la tête
je vous fais un petit peu la maman qui a
des câlins
avoir une information
folle contre laquelle on ne peut rien
maintenant je ne vois pas les choses
avec la même gravité les choses les
tracas de la vie et ça ça change
beaucoup ma façon de voir la vie